nous dépenserons ce dont nous avons besoin pour reconstruire
notre religion c'est l'investissement le moins cher
que nous puissions faire nous développerons
construire et acheter le meilleur équipement
connu de l'humanité
notre domination militaire doit être
incontestée
trop de destruction là-bas trop d'
armes destructrices au pouvoir de
l'armement est le plus gros problème
que nous ayons aujourd'hui dans le monde.
Enfin, je travaillerai avec nos alliés pour
revigorer les valeurs et les
institutions occidentales au lieu d'essayer de répandre des
valeurs universelles que tout le monde ne partage pas.
Nous devons comprendre que le
renforcement et la promotion de la
civilisation occidentale et de ses  les réalisations
feront plus pour inspirer des réformes positives
dans le monde que les
interventions militaires tout a commencé avec l'idée dangereuse
que nous pourrions faire des démocraties occidentales
des pays qui n'avaient aucune expérience
ou intérêt à devenir une démocratie occidentale
la meilleure façon d'atteindre ces objectifs est à
travers  une politique étrangère disciplinée, délibérée et
cohérente
et puis il y a Isis j'ai un
message simple pour eux leurs jours sont comptés
je ne leur dirai pas où et je ne
leur dirai pas comment nous devons nous devons en tant que nation être
plus imprévisibles
nous sommes totalement prévisibles nous disons
tout ce que nous sommes  en envoyant des troupes nous
leur disons que nous envoyons quelque chose d'autre nous
avons une conférence de presse nous devons être
imprévisibles et nous devons être
imprévisibles à partir de maintenant mais ils vont
partir Isis sera parti si
je suis élu président et ils '  ce sera
fait rapidement ce sera fait très très